back you are invited to Brave a haunted
bar for Halloween Rocky is live inside
the golden Tiki where things are getting
a little more freaky than usual this
week hi Rocky
hey I I feel oh my God see this is what
goes down at the golden Tiki if you get
some spirits to go with your spirits
right Adam you do absolutely absolutely
so tell everybody how this place is
actually haunted so yes it is 100
actually hauling it to you during
Halloween time you can go to a place
yeah so what do you see what happens so
most of it's pretty light-hearted and
fun but uh you'll see like little images
and pictures you take or little orbs but
then you sometimes you'll see like a
book fly off the shelf oh okay and then
I even had tables kind of glass tables
kind of shatter spontaneously no some
people might think they're just Tipsy
but no you're actually seeing a real
haunt so with that hunt you get some
drinks what's on the Halloween menu ooh
so we have a couple things so we have a
creamy delicious demon shot
um we have a classic 1934 South zombie
cockatiels okay now let's get ready to
make the next one okay
okay what's happening for six days of
freaky seeking oh so we have something
different every night we have fans
playing we have DJs kind of culminates
in a Halloween contest on Saturday night
always fun costume contest costume
contest and that one has a 500 grand
prize we're also doing a Monster's Ball
as well so yeah on Sunday night to see
if you want to be king or queen I love
it
oh I got some I got some Secrets I got a
tux I'm ready
to see it okay for yourself now do
people need to make a reservation can
they just walk in you know when they can
just walk in they can just walk in but
it's definitely reservations are
recommended because we get pretty busy
especially on the weekends especially
when cool things are happening okay to
know six days of freaky Tiki here at the
golden Tiki this drink is beautiful I'm
about to take a sip you guys Happy
Halloween and if you come down here and
something starts moving you're not just
drunk I'll send it back to you oh